amis de la caméra invisible bonsoir nous
sommes heureux nous sommes au comble de
la joie de vous retrouver en ce début de
saison
67 68 c'est comme ça qu'on dit c'est la
saison 68 cédait saison qui s'amorce
pour nous autres jours le spectacle et
les vacances sont déjà loin des bras
m'en sont déjà vous avez gardé quand
même votre bronzage pour le sage vérité
et vous vous n'avez pas faire de bronze
et rush balader quoi commenté un
brossage maltais oui j'étais raconte
rose a fallu non pas le mal par le mal
vous avez été hamad oui je dis je dis
qu'il a gardé ce bronzage de précise je
précise quand même pour les
téléspectateurs qui ne nous voient pas
ce soir qui n'ont pas l'heur de nous
voir encore en couleurs car nous passons
nous en couleurs les bras et je dois
dire que pierre bellemare en couleur tel
que je le vois là vous savez il a sa
petite cravate mis un spécial pour la
couleur mordorée rouge et bleu sur fond
de chemise bleu clair le pastel
moi j'ai une chemise bleu pastel je
continue à donner de détails pour le
noir et blanc une pochette d'ailleurs
dorénavant faudra donner je crois tous
les détails de couleurs pour les autres
comme on va continuer en cas de
défection comme ça et j'ai une pochette
rose c'est ravissant
m'enfin ne perdons pas de vue quand même
le côté document humain qui fait le fond
est l'intérêt de notre belle émission
[Musique]